I have
faith that everything can
change my mind is always making things
it's the way that I process my life if a
stephony Orchestra was created right now
what would that sound like we going to
play it one night only that Carnegie
Hall uh thank you for being here he
scored the your documentary from a few
years ago the first wave did the music
for that did this grow out of your
relationship with him and conversations
with him back in that time through a
friend Nick ptell I asked him to score
this documentary I made the first wave
um but it was a very like working
relationship like we didn't like hang
out or we didn't you know really know
each other that well and until we were
like we should probably have dinner and
so we had dinner he sort of was telling
me about American Symphony and his plans
and we both sort of turned to each other
we're like yeah we should probably
probably film this and at that point it
was a totally different conception it
was going to be this sort of process
film um um as he sort of drove around
the US gaining different musical
influences to help um put together this
um Symphony but then you know life
intervened he got nominated for 11
Grammys she got rediagnosis
as we were beginning shooting everything
had already shifted completely I think
of um cases in which people would
probably want some of the most private
moments they would like Sue to keep them
out of a documentary um was it
uh were there any rules did they have
rights to that or was it sort of a a
very organic relationship that was built
over um the course of the production
yeah well I think with any documentary
the foundation is built in trust and
they really trusted met and I think that
they trusted each other and they operate
with a cinch of such radical
vulnerability and knowing the importance
of sharing their story and what that
means for people to allow themselves to
be witnessed right and like the thing
that I say about Matt which really drew
me to his work in this project is that
he really Bears witness to all moments
of Life a lot of difficult moments but
he really Bears witness to the very
nuanced term of Bravery in people
whether it's people on the front lines
of a war or in a hospital room and I
think them knowing that about Matt they
just were down for the journey right and
I think that it's difficult to let
people shoot you
at your most vulnerable but you have to
have a level of trust like humano human
trust that
like my life is in this person's hands
and they're going to do right by me and
that was always
present you know Lauren mentioned your
your work in previous documentaries on
battlefields and front lines and in um
War
zones people have referred to this as
sort of a gear shift for you but uh do
you think of it that way I mean um um
there to me it it feels much like your
other work it just happens to be about
John Baptist to me it's the same process
I'm drawn
to you
know Fascinating People on some sort of
Journey overcoming some sort of obstacle
I mean that's all my docs have had some
element of that whether it's you know
cartels in Mexico Isis in Syria end of
the war in Afghanistan whatever it is
it's you know I I like I'm drawn to
people who are trying to overcome
something that is often insurmountable
you know my goal is to get as as deep
and intimate to their souls to their
beings to who they were as as possible
and to be able to be with
artists who are surviving as they say in
the movie with through their art during
this incredibly difficult moment of
their life was an unbelievable thing to
witness um and a really inspiring thing
to witness um but certainly when we
started we had no idea whether she like
it was going to survive we had no idea
what was going to happen and in fact she
was quite reticent about being part of
the film in the early days because she
did not want to be you know the sick
antidote to John's success um and so she
yeah took a lot of sort of trust
building and and and and conversations
transparent conversations about my
intentions our intentions um to get to
make her feel comfortable um to get into
that hospital
amazing um Lauren wanted to ask about
sort of the logistics it is a double
biography we do learn a lot about her um
and her as an artist and as a writer uh
but that meant sort of making sure that
there was a camera on her a lot uh do
how what was it like just juggling all
that I know so much footage was was
filmed yeah so to know Matt know is to
know that he believes in the power of AR
filming making and a camera is rolling
at all times so we had like, 1500 hours
of footage when I came in for the edit
uh and we had to sit through that
footage and figure out how we make a
film and I know that this is a thing
that a lot of filmmakers say of like I
could have made 11 different films but
when you have that much footage we
really could have made several different
films that show several different facets
of their lives uh but a big decision
that we made in the edit of like to hold
both of them at the same time to hold
the story like this film we talk so much
about balance of how in life we're all
constantly holding like a lot of grief
and a lot of Joy we're all holding it in
this room right now and how do we
measure that balance within the edit so
it's like we couldn't tell the story of
his his joy and only her sorrow right we
needed to explore her Joy too her
experience of painting right the power
of creativity that both of them are
using to navigate
uh the joy and the sorrow and I hope
that that's a lesson that viewers will
take with them I think especially in
this time that we're in in this moment
in the world we're all holding so much
and I hope a lot of people find you know
creative ways to channel that to make it
through as they do in the film and
Lauren do you want to maybe as we finish
up talk about the challenge uh of uh
Carnegie Hall where there were 13
cameras um and and you I think you were
there more than once right uh or was it
just the one time just the one time so
when John was initially supposed to
perform he got
co uh the night before the afternoon
before that performance uh day before
yeah um so everything was rescheduled
but again all the threads that we could
pull for this that didn't make it into
this film but yeah so we had a 13 camera
crew and of course as you see in the
film the power goes out uh and John just
being like a Visionary and like musical
Genius Like obviously handled it with
ease but if you someone asked recently
at a Q&A if that was real and I was like
oh if there was a camera in the like
camera setup camera station where you
see us freaking out cuz for us it's like
when you're in the moment you're not
thinking of how cinematic this will be
you're like holy crap this is the moment
that we've been gearing up to shoot and
now we're not going to have sound what's
happening um and then just see his grace
and again him being a channel and being
able to be like you know thank God we
had so many cameras so you can see him
for like a second be like oh and then be
handle it but yeah it was
really it was truly the most stressful
shoot in my uh in my career it was like
the power is out but like the lights are
on and does the audience know in the
reality was the power to the stage was
out um so like all the recording devices
weren't working all the electronics that
John had been using weren't working um
and so we knew that pretty quickly and
the only reason we have that scene is
obviously our cameras were working but
you know instead of using the 100
different mics that were set up for to
record John was recording for an album
too um you know the only audio for that
moment when he when he rifted was a
shotgun on the steady cam um and that's
like what we relied on there so I wanted
to just to um finish by actually talking
about this end of the film you know I
always love how you begin and end you
start in this snowy scene where he's
laying a little log down across a a
stream and then we end kind of in the
same place but in a much different place
it's still the the snow they're together
um what uh what is it saying about them
as a couple the beautiful thing about
that moment is that it allows us to
interpret as an audience member what's
happening and it's based on like your
own personal connection to cancer to
Survivor to Art right so I look at that
moment and I feel just because of my
personal connection to these themes that
they're looking forward to an uncertain
future and that helps me feel very seen
and like navigate my own feelings around
those themes in my own life of like you
can look forward with optimism to a
future that is deeply uncertain of what
lies ahead and we're like days late to
deliver the film to tell youde where the
film premiered and just didn't for me we
had ended the film for months at
Carnegie Hall he did this amazing Encore
rendition of the national anthem that's
really beautiful and pointed and tied
into the sort of grander themes of the
film but it just didn't feel to me the
story we were telling which at its core
is this to me this love story for me
docs can often be really
reductionistic in and sort of hand you
know spoon feeding you what to feel or
to think and that's you know I love
allowing audiences to interpret many you
know the the complex greyness of life um
and so it's not a sort of them walking
off into the sunset moment to me it's
them just continuing to walk forward
have JN and cica seen it with an
audience she asked specifically that she
wanted to watch the film alone for the
first time she didn't remember most of
what you see in the film because of all
the Cancer drugs and painkillers that
she was on so it
was incredibly emotional for her to
watch it um and she had to watch it a
few times just to sort of like process
the trauma of all that she she'd been
through um but yeah I think you know
seeing for them seeing an audience was
just really um I think it touched them a
lot to see people react and laugh and
cry and I don't know what the energy in
this room was but there you know there
was at when we premiered to tell you
right just there's a real special energy
in that room I think they it meant a lot
to them yeah and I think both of them
have had the experience after screenings
of people in the audience coming up to
them and telling them you know wow I'm
going to look at my life differently or
I've been impacted by cancer and I've
not really blocked it out and I've not
thought about it and this is like
bringing up a lot of like raw emotions
and allowing people to process um so
yeah they they hold a lot of space they
create a really safe container when
they're at screenings but yeah it's been
really a really beautiful
reception congratulations again on this
beautiful film and thank you both so
much for coming with us
tonight thank you all for coming out
tonight and spending it with
[Applause]
us